good morning vo Higgins we're about to
cross over to kannan arya messier today
are we gonna see the O'Higgins glacier
it seems you made it to the end of the
character roster the O'Higgins lake is
shared by Chile and Argentina and has a
surface area of 1013 square kilometers
it's the deepest lake in the Americas
with a maximum depth of eight hundred
thirty-six meters near o'higgins glacier
the glacier is located in the bernardo
o'higgins National Park and is one of
the biggest in the southern Patagonian
ice field
so what do you do when you are at a
glacier whiskey whiskey with glacier ice
good morning from KLRU Mencia which we
already left behind we're under way to
the border control before we before we
cross the border um for like about
almost of all day 22 kilometers yeah and
the first 16 kilometers we will walk
without our luggage yeah but the last
five we have to take it ourselves
because we thought there were horse
quarters but I guess they don't they
have the day huh so we're gonna carry
like 20 kilos each of stuff for about
five days
after hiking for about 60 kilometers we
made it to the actual border over there
is chili and there it is Argentina go
for it go to Argentina Ricardo just gave
us the bags who drove them up as far as
he could but since there are no horses
we have to carry them the rest of the
way through mud then Steve's been really
lovely and taking some of the weight
from my bags but five kilometres is
gonna be a long way with all this
this is a real challenge people doing
well so far it hurts but we need to
fight maybe like three backpacks I'm
really backpackers feed after spending a
night at the southern shore we hitchhike
to the remaining thirty seven kilometers
to el chalten nowadays it's Argentina's
trekking capital and one of the most
beautiful hiking areas in Patagonia
we'll be in touch from their next time